les soignants était applaudit chaque
soir au début de la pandémie si
aujourd'hui l'hôpital public et à la
limite du burn-out en pleine crise
sanitaire
5700 lit en été supprimée en 2020 pour
suivant en processus enclencher depuis
plusieurs années en 1/5 et aujourd'hui
fermé dans les grands hôpitaux publics
faute de personnel l'obligation
vaccinale pour les professionnels de
santé a certainement quelque chose à
voir là-dedans moins de lit moins de
personnel moins de moyens financiers moi
de tout sauf de malade qui plus est en
cette période de pandémie qui est choco,
19 c'est arrivé à savoir réel pour la
prise en charge des patients mais elle a
aussi mis en lumière un certain nombre
de difficultés un sou investissement
dans la santé un nombre de personnes en
nombre insuffisant
investissement dans la santé c'est la
même du locataire de Matignon voile ce
que disait de nuit son prédécesseur
Édouard Philippe en avril 2020 lorsqu'il
a chargé Jean Castex de mener un travail
de réflexion sur les stratégies de
déconfinement de la population au
fonctionnaire qui connaît parfaitement
le monde de la santé et qui est
redoutable d'efficacité redoutable
d'efficacité dans la casse de l'hôpital
public peut-être parce qu'avant d'être
monsieur déconfinement et Premier
ministre Jean Castex était d'abord entre
2006 et 2007 directeur de cabinet de
Xavier Bertrand alors ministre de la
Santé il a été le promoteur de la
réforme de la tarification dit T2 à elle
a fait de l'hôpital fait une entreprise
de production de soins avec elle
l'établissement ne reçois plus de budget
destiné à répondre à des besoins mais
rémunéré d'après sa productivité ce
système nécessite un gros travail de
pédagogie il a le mérite d'obliger tous
les établissements à se regarder avec
lucidité
pays qui ont mis en œuvre ce type de
tarification ont dû attendre 4 ou 5 ans
avant que le modèle se stabilise
et bien plus dégradé
en est l'un des mots les plus graves
dans les hôpitaux à l'accès le conduit
les médecins à augmenter la cadence à
réduire la durée des consultations voir
à prescrire des soins pas toujours
adapté l'adoption en 2004 de la
tarification à l'activité est la réforme
la plus structurante du secteur
hospitalier depuis 30 ans elle a
considérablement changer la prise en
charge on est en effet aller vers
l'industrialisation de la médecine
hospitalière la T2A et on était le
principal levier de l'augmentation de la
production mais là où c'est
particulièrement pernicieux c'est quand
même moment on a renforcé à l'hôpital la
contrainte budgétaire autrement dit les
mesures d'économie les directeurs
d'hôpitaux vendons compris mais les
dépenses de personnel qui représentent
65 % des dépenses ensuite augmente
l'activité les malades reste par
conséquent hospitalisé le moins
longtemps possible parce qu'il faut
faire du chiffre forcément au détriment
de la qualité cela a mis le personnel
dans des positions atteignable
transformer l'hôpital en usine à profit
force est de constater que le projet ne
fonctionne pas et cela Emmanuel Macron
l'avais déjà reconnu je suis en 2018 et
aujourd'hui étranglé par un système
devenu comptable qui s'appelle la
tarification à l'activité nous avons des
services qui se vide où il y a des gens
qui sont là et qui ne devrait pas y
rester parce que l'on fait des actes
inutiles pour toucher justement la
tarification à l'activité malgré cet
aveu d'Emmanuel Macron la T2A est
toujours aussi présente aujourd'hui le
chef de l'État a même fait du promoteur
de cette mesure le chef du gouvernement
à face à l'effondrement de l'hôpital
public l'exécutif a tenté de rectifier
le tir avec le Ségur de la santé en plan
d'investissement de 19 milliards d'euros
pour soutenir le système de santé c'est
beaucoup pas sûr pour autant que cela
suffise à terme